what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay I want to try something new here um
I like trying out new ideas just to see
how they do and and to see how people
react to them and so on and so forth you
guys do not know but you are my
experiments
you guys are my test subjects for ideas
and concepts and so on so forth so uh
experimenting on you I am a mad
scientist um I want to try my hand at
creating a video series called things
you didn't know and in this first video
which kind of makes the most sense the
Joker knows he's a comic book character
and here's how we know that so the Joker
knows this and we know that we know we
make believe that we don't know and the
Joker makes believe that he believes
that we don't know but knows that we
know everybody knows I love you guys
ever saw under siege dark territory ah
not as good as the first one that's what
my favorite scenes with that one guy
cannot I can never remember his name
anyway so yes the Joker knows usually
coming with character now here's the
thing uh one of the big questions people
ask here is has the Joker ever broken
the fourth wall now for those of you
guys who don't know what that means when
it comes to breaking the fourth wall in
comic books it's literally addressing
the audience and we'll talk more about
that here in a second with regards to
the history of it but the Joker's done
this before and he did it in continuity
this came in 2010 with a boards that a
Batman Batman 80-page special there was
basically like a whole bunch of short
stories all of or at least I think it
kind of you can kind of pick and choose
which ones are in continuity but the one
with the Joker the first story you get
is the one that's in continuity and the
Joker is kind of crazy and he's an
Arkham and you know going on you know
kills a doctor that kind of thing and
the whole idea is that at the end of it
he kind of addresses the question of if
he if he's crazy he's like am I crazy of
course I'm crazy you know he's like but
uh you know I'm talking to my imaginary
friends I mean art like does that make
me crazy and then like he addresses the
audience and says you are imaginary
right like you know that's that's the
whole like like that right there Joker
brookie the fourth wall means the Joker
knows he's to come up a character
because if he didn't he would never
address the audience now the question is
how do I get to that conclusion okay so
let's talk about the idea of breaking
the fourth wall a lot of people
attribute this to Deadpool which
Deadpool made it popular at least uh he
was the one that really kind of blew it
you know blew and blew the doors off on
it made it into a great big huge thing
but by and large it started with
she-hulk so when John Byrne took over
the she-hulk solo series oh really like
launched the she-hulk solo series Kirk
hovers always had her breaking the
fourth wall and the first issue was
something like hey this is my first run
make sure you know I really hope you
guys enjoy the story set along those
lines once he got to the point where it
wasn't really selling and Marvel was
gonna cancel it then she would say
things like like like we're running out
options here like you got to buy this
story we're gonna get cans
and then on the last issue was something
along those lines it was like well you
guys didn't want to buy my comic so now
we're getting canceled and it was that's
that's where the whole thing came from
with with breaking the fourth wall and
she Hawk and there were some people who
did it you know a little bit after that
with Deadpool that's when everything
changed because what you had back in the
day is you had this idea of Joe Kelly
riding the Deadpool comics and the
reason why that works is because at the
time Deadpool was like a hold over
Deadpool was introduced back in the old
in the old New Mutants stories which
were turned into the x-force stories
which uh you ended up having Rob Liefeld
right for a little while and Deadpool
kind of showed up here and there and
then really he got a solo series or at
least a miniseries with a circle chase
by Mark Waid and that was spun out into
his own solo series but when Joe Kelly
and Ed McGuinness took over maama didn't
really care they were just like
published thing who cares like his his
audience is basically gone he has no
real place in Marvel Comics because the
era of high-octane stories with like GW
bridge and like cable and I was guys
it's all basically gone now so I know a
lot of old people just like damn GW
bridge that's a name I haven't heard in
a long long time and there's no reason
for you to if he showed up nobody would
care like he'd showed up for one issue
and people just be like who the hell's
that and then just close it out and just
be done with it but anyway so when Joe
Kelly took over the title there was one
point where where Deadpool broke the
fourth wall for the first time and he
was he was talking about Wolverine or or
Kitty Pryde or something like that
and just kind of made an offhand remark
it was crazy too because he was just
like an old woman
and then he did it one more time any
there's one point we actually uppercuts
Kitty Pryde out of the out of the panel
and then eventually like Joe Kelly and
Ed McGinnis leave like Emma Guinness
drew it for like the first seven or
eight issues and then Joe Kelly wrote it
for a little more than he leaves and
then you start getting like these
subsequent writers like gail simone
writes it for a little while and like a
handful other people write deadpool for
a little while and then it goes to
christopher priest and at the time
christopher priest was the writer that
you sent comics to when you wanted to
cancel it like when you wanted to get
rid of them and is one of the funny
things when deadpool when when chris her
priest first takes over deadpool ends up
going to this trailer for like cancelled
cancelled titles and what he gets in
there there's like iron fist and like
Moon Knight and so on and so forth and
Deadpool's like nope not gonna happen
and he literally jumps into a pool of
water and the story kicks off with him
in a tank and and that's where they know
that's where the whole thing goes and
but it became like common practice
because we're free to just have him
break the fourth wall and so it was kind
of ironic the guy who is the pewte the
person that Marvel goes to to cancel
heroes actually made Deadpool all the
more popular and he's been a mainstay
with breaking the fourth wall ever since
but the whole idea behind that is
Deadpool's basically crazy like he's out
of his mind and because he's so insane
he can break the fourth wall without any
real regard or anything like that the
Joker never really does that that often
the Joker never really breaks the fourth
wall and in fact this is really the only
story I can find that that's in
continuity where the Joker actually does
it there's never been an instance as far
as I'm aware anytime before that that's
in continuity with the Joker did that
like an emperor Joker he may have and a
couple other times but this basically
establishes like the Joker knows he's a
comic book character now that brings him
to sharp relief the question is that the
reason why the Joker is crazy it's not
the reason why the Joker is out of his
mind is because he knows he's a kind of
a character and doesn't care what he
does the problem with this is that
different writers have taken different
liberties with the insanity of the Joker
like if you go and you read the old
Steve Englehart comics from back in the
70s I think it was or the 80s you
basically get Joker from Batman the
Animated Series you go read like the
really really old Batman comics from the
1940s where you had like Bob Kane and
Bill Finger who wrote and drew the whole
thing and you get like really dark
sadistic Joker you read like scott
Snyder's new 52 run you get a far more
sinister Joker who's actually just
totally screwed up and cuts his face off
but in none of those instances does he
ever truly break the fourth wall does he
ever truly addressed the reader there is
one common from back in the day and I
cannot remember for the life of me what
issue it is it escapes me so bad but
there is one point where the Joker turns
a page for the audience which is kind of
crazy this is the only time the Joker
ever actually addresses us as the reader
and so that establishes Joker breaking
the fourth wall that means that Joker is
aware of us is the audience reading
about its chemical character and if he's
aware of us as the audience reading
about his comic book character then he
knows he's a comic book character and so
that's kind of a cool thing because then
the question becomes like what could you
do with that like what do you what could
you do with the idea of the Joker
breaking the fourth wall and what you
could what could you do with him knowing
these a comical character see honestly
it's difficult to tell because the Joker
is like the number one greatest comic
book villain of all time at least if you
go and look at the various I guess like
the various poles and things like that I
would see the Joker is the most popular
comic book villain of all time like no
doubt like like bar none I would say
he's probably the most popular comic
book villain to ever exist everybody
knows who the Joker is I mean it's the
Joker man you can walk out you can walk
up to like an 80 year old lady on the
street and show her a picture of the
Joker say who's this she's like that's
the that's the guy the Joker Batman
villain like the joking guy you know she
may not know exactly who he hears me I
don't I don't know why she wouldn't but
maybe like that's the Joker let your
mind knows who the Joker is you know
Joaquin Phoenix doesn't look anything
like the Joker and I just want to get
that out of here like let's just all sit
down
say he doesn't look anything on - Joker
doesn't mean the movie will be bad but
he does not look like the Joker we can
all universally agree as well dad Mark
Hamill was the best version of the Joker
Heath Ledger's a close second but of
course Mark Hamill played the the voice
of the Joker in the animated series but
without Mark Hamill the animated series
Joker would not have been nearly as
interesting but with you know with this
whole thing going on the problem you
have there is that with the Joker
knowing usually come up a character I
think him continuing on the path that he
is which is to say just being crazy and
sinister actually works because if they
decided to adopt the Deadpool moniker
the Deadpool concept of the Joker and
have him breaking the fourth wall all
the time it would take away from him it
would take away from the interest in the
in his character but the Joker being so
screwed up being obsessed with Batman
all those things that's what makes it
kind of cool if he interesting to see
like an offhand remark that he says you
know where he says like all it doesn't
like it doesn't matter if you catch me
like I'm gonna go back to Arkham Asylum
because you know and I'll get back out
again because that's what the writers
want that would be kind of a cool thing
and that's one of the things that people
usually look for when they say like a
character break you know a character
knowing there's a comic book character
Deadpool does it all the time and
Deadpool did it and Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe and Deadpool Killa
straighted and Deadpool kills Deadpool
the whole basis behind those stories was
that wade knew he was a coming of a
character like that was a whole point
like Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
because he realizes that they're
basically trapped in a cycle of being
killed off by riders and being restored
again and decided to kill them all and
there's actually one point I think in
Deadpool killest rated where he
eventually goes and kills the entire
writing artist and editing staff for the
Deadpool line and is just like you guys
are done because all you guys do is keep
killing us it's kind of funny it's kind
of interesting but that's that's the
thing I mean there's overt recognition
that someone in a comic is a character
that they're not real and then there's a
subtle hint to it where the Joker it's
more of a subtle hint there's more of a
subtle like statement the Joker knows
he's a come-up a character but nothing
ever comes of it after that with
Deadpool you see all the time he
recognizes full-on that he's a care of
these they come up with character and it
doesn't matter and it's not something
you see like well used to see it all the
time you don't really see it so much
anymore uh him breaking the fourth wall
isn't something that happens all the
time it's one of those things that
people knew happen and so they assume
that it's still going on at the moment
and occasionally he'll do it but again
it's one of those weird things I just
kind of won to establish that you know
some of you didn't know like the Joker
broke the fourth wall once and that
means Joker's aware that he's a comical
character but let me know what you guys
think I'm kind of curious you know it
doesn't matter to you guys that Joker
knows he's a comic book character is it
relevant to you guys you guys care at
all would you prefer that the Joker
doesn't know he's a comic book here -
like does that sound more
because I know there's a lot of a lot of
diehard Joker fans out there and I know
there's a lot of die-hard fans out there
who does kind of like take this comic
sweep it under the rug and pretend like
it doesn't exist and call it a day let
me know what you guys think I'm really
kind of curious and let me know anything
about this series to you about this this
video idea because in college is all
kinds of little tidbits I mean for the
hardcore reader
they'll probably know this stuff but for
the average Joe they probably wouldn't
like you know different things like that
so let me know what you guys think and
yeah we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here too comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the rod war if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later
peace
[Music]